yeah hello and welcome to this video
coverage of the 11th game of the World
Championship match yeah this is the
final game where the Challenger is the
white pieces so that looks like a good
try for okay I can do maybe do something
in this match before it gets to the tie
breaks Carlton has leveled this coin
game 10 and now there are only two games
left kayaking widen 11 cards and white
in the final game um yeah first of all
quick mentioned that video is on a
little bit on the late side um that game
was played on saturday already I've been
away on a tournament and I couldn't do
the recording earlier and then then now
but um let's get going not waste any
more time so unsurprisingly we've got 14
um kayaking has tried to d4 once in the
match force laughs but that also didn't
didn't get anywhere I mean cousin I've
got got a good position out of the
opening then display that study and got
to a draw but still um II for his kayak
ins men move so he goes with this year
again and unsurprisingly we have another
width and it returns to the d3 line yeah
kayaking I didn't get anywhere in the
end time Marshall that he had played
earlier he had two NT Marshalls that
were relatively first a very easy draw
for Carlton and then a game where he
suffered a lot so it was 263 um okay
this is the same line as already
witnessed in game number Q I believe
when Carlton played on 95 you should
back and then we should be six and that
was I think
easy draw firm in this game he plays
differently he plays the move Bishop e6
immediately and interesting love of a
night after 95 to play tonight to deform
there is a line that has been played
quite a bit in tournament chess and it
was something that I personally had
never seen which probably just shows my
ignorance for this line and it's
something that is has been seen quite a
bit when i played this with black i
usually play entirely differently I
plane probably I should look at
something else but I usually play with
Knight a5 and then sometimes c5 but that
might not be the best choice um okay so
this is an interesting idea night your
form is a very direct move not aiming
for a long ish strategic battle but
rather changing the pawn structure
really and this fields quite logical
they've got those trades and now and
take care and taking only six also
fairly obvious so we got some minor
pieces traded early on and what this
means a little bit of a simplification
of the position but that does not mean
that it is necessarily going to be a
quick draw no fight at all that is
simply to tyranny and here white has
tried a couple of moves in high-level
chess or very logical looking and what
it f was played by kayaking but they're
spinning and with begins with a for
Bishop d to clean g-form but f-for is
also perfectly logical him what about
this position um white has a little bit
more space that's quite quite clear with
a 40 point F for the point point dual
black however is not suffering sorry so
much from this lack of space because he
has traded so many pieces there's just
one mind
he's left the bishop on f6 so that lack
of space is not a not a big deal we
should say that black actually has some
space himself on the queenside there he
got actually more space but white has
more play in the center on the King side
and what is important is that blacks
pawn structure is a little bit loose
yeah those pawns him they can be
attacked some time and they are easier
targets than whites pawns all in all I
think it's fairly equal disposition and
they will see that both players um yeah
they get to an interesting position just
a couple of months later Queen g4 looks
normal yeah attacking the pawn down and
27 also the most natural move in the
world and even this is a known position
and now f5 was played by kayaking this
is probably the most straightforward
move available and just the Tecla
structure immediately and of course
there's also an argument to be made for
for slow moves like Bishop t2 and just
try to complete development right at
five why not and it's important to him
that black um yeah plays the right the
right decision now he played rook to e8
and and the move that is going to be
extremely risky here would be e five
yeah there's actually something where
the computer does not really have any
objection about but for a human player
this idea looks extremely risky because
white has an automatic attack yeah with
stuff like g42 g5 of course black has a
counter play um maybe actually for that
reason you would rather want to go here
okay I don't want to analyze this in
detail the movie 5 is strategically very
risky the bishop looks bad and white has
an automatic attack so understandable
that Carson I wanted to keep the tension
and playbook to create yeah kayaking
took a bit of time now I'm played at the
end this is no move Bishop d2 very
logical you need to connect groups white
could always opt for this yeah go go for
this chatting but he have the likelihood
of the draw is of course very very high
the pawn structure is very symmetrical
and black for example like here here as
it would post him from the bishop only
five um if anybody white can do a little
bit of something in this kind of ending
because those pawns here a little bit
easier to attack in some cases if you
imagine what somehow entering the
position with a form that can go before
it's very much blocked so that was a
very simple solution that kayaking had
available however he didn't do that he
played Bishop e2 as we said and garden
now with c4 yeah he goes with this Queen
side break um looks perfectly logical it
wasn't the only move for you also could
have played something more conservative
like taking on at five but as we will
see consonance game plan here is to try
a little bit of something from this
position without taking any unduly risk
I think he did a good job down and yak I
can now play the moves age three
covering the Queen this is a generally
useful move the queen is covered which
can be quite useful if you take care for
example and there are sometimes
discoveries so the Queen being covered
as is useful also you give some
additional space lift for them for the
king yeah and now very interesting
moment when I was watching this game and
I could watch it actually because I had
returned from my tournament by the time
this game was was going and when I was
watching um I didn't expect this this
to move that all and i think i'm not
alone with that also the commentators
were very surprised that this was a
playable option so what did Carson do
you plan to move c3 and this initially
seemed very risky because you think
automatically okay white has to take and
we don't need to argue about that they
are playing this is very strange move so
whatever it's even stranger so it takes
and now you automatically assume
Blackwood caption and after Bishop e3
you wonder what exactly was the point
yeah isn't white the one who's coming
out on top here with the better central
control very strange the thing is that
didn't happen after c3 indeed of course
kayaking tour but now the world champion
did not recapture on c3 but went for the
very interesting defiled all of a sudden
provoking a big crisis in the center
yeah very for me very surprising turn of
events and it is it I think this is
really strong play black is trying to
yeah make something out of first his
bishop with this action c3 and now that
the bishop is doing something there's
ideas like taking Bishop d4 check and
he's activating here the rooks that he
has en fr especially the rukon de file
because currently what black has he is a
little bit quicker and development just
a little bit the rook is just on still
on a1 this pawn can potentially be weak
now so it actually it opens up the
center in a situation where black is a
little bit better prepared for that and
the position is equal actually um but
it's white who has to the attitude to be
very precise in fact there are some ways
to to go wrong and here already there's
a big decision for kayaking I think he
took almost 30 minutes
let us check this quickly yeah like for
the sad 50 27 minutes yeah very
understandable because here there are a
couple of options that are and this has
very far-reaching consequences the
decision you take here will shape the
rest of the game so he actually had a
continuation that basically suggests
itself but it has some deep points that
should not be underestimated if you
tried to evaluate its otay taking that's
what I'm talking about this is at least
the first move that I would check let's
just see what happens there thing is
takes t-check ticks ticks that's easy to
see two pawns why these two pawns up but
there's rookie 2 and this is actually
very very awkward now the bishop is
hanging you have no good way to no good
place to put it and if you'll cover it
then black is taking here and is ready
for Bishop to g4 plus c2 is hanging this
is actually winning straight away whitey
only has one move to keep equality and
this is a somewhat scary move to play
look at you yeah after the capture and
black takes black is ready for double
check double-check discovery but it
seems that there's nothing terrible
happening too wide after we should be
one it looks extremely scary though
really does and you are also need to
assess correctly what happens if black
takes the spot which is possible um I
think this is equal but it's not easy to
play into this it looks extremely scary
so this is the first move you'll
probably consider and you come to the
conclusion moon not easy and a move that
the engine is suggesting here is the
movie form certainly also something that
can be checked um yeah what is blacks
best
against this probably should take on
your form and now we have interesting
complications why it can take on you for
I can take on b5 this is this is a
completely crazy position I get this for
example you have this is absolutely
crazy you have no idea what's going on
here completely a complete mess now the
kind of thing you probably want in the
present in a game where you need to win
at all costs and one can also take on a
form and after be takes again I think
the position is probably roughly equal
and all this seems like white is not
playing for an advantage and kayaking
probably and correctly so I mean this is
this general med strategy if it gets
kind of unclear or if there is the
possibility to to enter something
something a little bit tough to assess
he tends to go for a simplification and
n term yeah he went for this morning and
this is a good simplification I think in
some cases I felt that the Challenger
was avoiding too much in case of
complicated play but he I think it's a
very wise decision there are other
things are tough to assess and you risk
actually off maybe a Gabby being worse
if you are if you don't assess it
correctly and we have to really see the
situation in two games left if kayaking
loses this white game the match is
basically done I mean he's not going to
win with black against cars if cars
needs to draw I think it's very that
seems very tough to do so he has to
really handle it with extreme care I
mean Cardin of course also cannot really
afford a loss here but at least is got
white in the final game if something
went wrong here so Bishop g5 I think
it's a good move it simplifies the
situation even though still car that is
trying its best to do something
taking here on e4 um yeah at the end
here kayaking took on is 6d takes e4
probably wasn't as good this is the the
the easy way to do it check got the
trade in and the Queen captured so if we
do a count yet we have six points each
but why it can take on d4 so why does
upon up here cousin has a choice and
again he does not go for the simple
continuation he tries to set problems he
could have he wanted to just a simple
draw I could have just taken only three
this is the kind of the kind of Jack
choice to clarify matters entirely here
we probably will have an easy draw
coming because the three points it will
probably trade against the two points
ultimately like for example um but what
is that what is a plus I didn't look at
this so much but let's make a line out
of it let's say black goes to go here so
something like that that's not forced
yeah that's probably that's probably
good enough way of drawing it the
rupiah's is controlling this and why
there's no way forward if he pushes the
pawn he has to be cautious that the
black king is not not coming up so this
is the droid is that I was wrong with
saying everything will get traded
probably but you could probably create
something like that with them yeah I
don't think a five is any good but this
is good enough yeah Black is just just
staying here it is fine this is simply
never playing so that was an easy way of
doing it but Carson plate III keeping
keeping the game keeping the game going
and ultimately he does not risk all that
much because if we if we check this the
pawn is quite strong the e3 porn and
white has
doesn't really have many options here to
activate he basically has to stay with
the rook on the first rank to prevent
the poem from promotion and with such a
passive rook you're never going to win
but still ikik needs to be precise now
they're not not doing anything but doing
anything stupid he plays sorry wrong
button he plays rupee one where the rook
has to go anyway 86 giving some
additional space down for the king and
is to ya in a bullet game you might
cking F to Queenie three mates but not
in a world championship match and Tina
three cret f 3 i'm sorry is a very
logical move the Queen goes near the
pond note that white can never pick this
up by King f2 because of room to f8
winning the Queen so a five plate yeah
so you should not underestimate us if
white is now playing when he has to play
pretty badly to to allow that but you
never know you can imagine let's say
something something like this yep and
this is getting very very ugly how do
you defend against this so c3 is a good
choice we are not allowing any before
tricks Queen eight you again this is the
most active youth and the Queen might go
here and again this is something that
you would want to prevent if Y
displaying something stupid now let's
say again something something lame then
after Queen d2 you have to be again very
very precise something like that you
would probably not hold in the long run
yeah comes to you three and so on this
is a strong move but I can this is
actually the move that that makes this
position
now a pretty clear drawn it's a
counter-attack this is coming with the
temp check and ce4 is strong attacking
the rook yeah and now black has to force
the draw basically and this is with the
Queen d2 attacking the rook there is no
way now for why to continue he has to
take care check and in this situation
why does threatening a perpetual so
after Queen f2 black wants to promote
but check Mini 4 ends the draw and it's
a game now with the draw yeah this is
check the perpetual g6 check again check
doesn't change anything it is a draw now
so this game ended in a draw the
penultimate game of this match there is
just one game left that's going to be
played on November 28 so today on the
release set of that video this will be a
yeah very thrilling conclusion we have a
2 25.5 points each so it's down to one
game the the guy wins this game is the
new or new world champion or cars and it
takes a retains the title and if we have
a drawing that game that will be a rapid
and possibly blitz playoff on wednesday
wednesday the 30th so we can definitely
look forward to to the end of this
conclusion of this very very tight match
I talk to a student of mine earlier what
what my estimates are how this ends I
get from Carlton twenty percent chance
of winning this game to a game twelve
like twenty to thirty percent because I
think he has the psychological
initiative now in this in the situation
ten percent ok I came to win and yeah
sixty to seventy percent likelihood over
our rapid and blitz tiebreaker I give
her the pretty decent chance I think
with this with this win was immensely
ortant of course it was yeah but I mean
also from a psychological point of view
he now knows he can win a game against
the sky and it is the this game also
shows that he is ready to take those
calculated risk is wrong but he tries to
to make the best out of the positions
and and set some problems ok I can hear
could solve all of them and we'll see
how it how it goes in the final game I
expect you for once again I expect
another ruler PES actually every and
something else would surprise me but you
never know and I expect something
similar like game 10 in terms of terms
of strategy ok guys thanks for watching
I'll be covering the final game as well
of course bye bye